[Musique]
bon je dois pas de plus un pour le
mariage
j'allais jouer avec ma meuf t'a une meuf
non mais je pensais peut-être la
rencontre année c'est la c5 a annoncé un
peu plus tard tu sais parfois seul que
mal accompagné un jour oui journée c'est
du génie pas de façon j'ai le temps
c'est quand le mariage demain
[Musique]
être adulte c'est aussi ne pas céder à
la pression du système qui nous impose
d'être en couple obligatoirement alors
qu'on peut très bien être célibataire et
heureux un même si être en couple c'est
quand même cool
enfin bref non mais là ouais lors
bénédicte dorothée donc non mec tu vas
pas choisi de filer au hasard comme ça
faut que je trouve quelqu'un qui te
correspond vraiment pas raison là il
faut pas un plus un là il faut vraiment
que je trouve la ferme de ma vie là
ouais ouais c'est vrai que tu vas
réussir à faire en 24 heures ce que t'as
jamais réussi à faire en 29 ans j'ai
activé l'option premium à 2 0 ou à
concevoir c'est vrai tu me prêtes à
carte ce qui est way jeu de baston wayne
rap us oui mon gars obligé en d'orgueil
peut se trouver une fille qui correspond
à tous critères lancer la recherche un
profil trouver un monsieur médisants
toujours propre fils c'est le mien je
correspond à mes critères at aux siens
tu as dû larguer pour nice oui j'ai une
solution tu le largue ensemble au
mariage comme ça tu deviens mon bus ans
on n'aura pas accouché en sont et on se
regarde les deux à bord est carrément
joie passé l'arc le jv la mer monte
encore là c'est pas la requête
tu prends corps communs et tu vas le
parquet comme cela
[Musique]
bon je vais orné où wayne gerdes avec
une meuf du web l' angoisse et une meuf
j'ai vu son visage dans un reflet sur
une photo elle est très très belle allez
ciao le geek c'est la bonne
bien sûr bon c'est une super machine
mais il faut les laver régulièrement
d'accord donc vous avez différents modes
question basse saxe a aucun rapport mais
qui se fait dans la vie différents modes
différents modes les modes puissant
rapide puissant rapide voit donc femmes
actives peut-être sa liberté le mât de
gâteaux cateau et le match brillant chez
ba voyage c'est ça c'est ce que j'aime
ça je suis très brioche la base bon ben
maintenant tu as un mini frigo
alors c'est par mini frigo c'est ma
fille n'a pas été super cher et je lui
ai un très bon prix en plus il ya un
mode brioche
wauquiez bon ok c'est pas neuf j'appelle
mes ex non norman appel pathé sexe entre
noisy-le-sec
j'appelle seulement celle là qui s'est
jamais rien passé et c'est resté en
suspens parce que tout à l'heure
ouais parce que tous à l'eau coule in
ouais c'est normal on est un cas très
bon soir des faits un tpe sur sur adolf
hitler
ça va à l'eau
comment séduire une fille en moins d'une
technique elle est pas négligeable
l'avez vous très important de se laver
certains mecs négligé cet aspect là
pourtant il faut se laver dont pour
apprendre à larguer son mec de façon
très simple il ya plusieurs types de
mythos du genre est trop bien pour moi
je suis désolé mais malheureusement j'ai
l'impression que je te tire vers le bas
ils ne sont pas capables d'être avec toi
je me sens vraiment trop nuls par
rapport à toi et je pense que tu
trouveras mireia ça généralement ça
passe toujours plutôt bien plus vite te
plaît voilà père je suis à fond là
sur ces 26 et bien sûr ses écrits la
regarde aller partout vase et je peux
être une chaise suis d'accord c'est pas
une route d'accra vas-y voilà ce qu'ils
font aucun profil aux alentours
merde
chloé 28 clos et que et ensuite on avait
une affinité
on aime bien le badminton peut-être que
t'es pas fait pour vivre avec quelqu'un
et des gens ils sont tous seuls toute
leur vie sera votre superbe tient laurie
à m'acheter une cravate pour demain quel
état vont bien et vous c'est une femme
parfaite marie toi avec ta femme
parfaite la peine
ma chance
il faut pas forcer les choses je suis
sûr que le jour tu qui attendra pas
épais tu vas tomber sur la femme de ta
vie comme ça je trouve cette femme au
sort rien un anniversaire baba remis
cela n'importe où et un mariage ça
marche oui ça c'est connu dans le
mariage elle décide matière moi quand
j'étais jeune
pour pécho gel des mariages à ne pas
voter c'est bon ça va le faire
[Musique]